six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go next to our caller from the 804
area code caller from 804 go ahead oh
hey Kimmy we can hear you yeah okay good
thank you yeah my name is Sheldon mom I
see from Virginia um yeah I had an
interesting question because I started a
video on the pseudo-intellectual and I
thought it was rather interesting
however I don't quite agree with how you
guys sound one about combating them
because in my opinion at least people
seem to have a very short attention
spans yeah in the way they can just you
know spout talking points just very
quickly like rapidly you know like you
don't make America great again or you
know other just simple slogans it's kind
of hard from that because then you have
to so it kind of break it down piece by
piece plug by point in box having done
that I think you've lost most of the
audience that's why I think that's
driving so I was wondering if you think
that you know just kind of comparing
them on the ideal basis was a good idea
so let's see if we can take a step back
for a second Sheldon because I want to
understand what you're saying you're you
you said you don't think that my view
about how to combat pseudo intellect in
talega lism is a good one
what are you referring to what did I say
was my my approach to combating it
well um correct me if I'm wrong but
could I'm the video you posted a few
days ago but I was I think through
basically the way you kind of did the
video at least seems like you broke down
the point it kind of point-by-point well
you know what they do how they're
thriving and why they're thriving but in
you kind of seems like you kinda just
break in and down point by point which
is a good idea don't get me wrong I
think that's a good idea but I wanted it
the long time if it was really going to
be successful
oh ya know so just because I did a
breakdown on my show doesn't mean that I
think that the solution to pseudo and
anti intellectualism is to at every
opportunity
do like detailed point-by-point
breakdowns I agree with you that's not
the path forward and in fact I actually
said in a story a few weeks ago that the
answer to pseudo intellectual ism is not
just intellectualism because there's a
reason why the pseudo intellectual ists
pseudo int and when I say pseudo
intellectual lists I don't mean the
pseudo-intellectuals I mean the pseudo
intellectual list like the followers of
pseudo intellectual is they are drawn to
this stuff because of the sort of
charismatic and comforting straight-4
word nature of what these individuals
are presenting so I actually I wish I
had a specific plan for how to combat it
but I'm not actually totally sure okay
yes I'm just kind of my boat that
regards like you know I'm not really
quite sure how to do it I honestly don't
want to employ their taxes because that
would make them know better but it's
kind of like a slippery slope but you
know there is an argument that some
people make Sheldon which is if you
believe if you disagree with the way
that they do their thing but you believe
that it's a reasonable means to an end
to adopt their tactics if it disabuse
--es people of those beliefs there's an
argument to be made like we're stooping
to their level in terms of exactly but
it's worth it in the end right and it's
sort of like a moral decision you have
to make I don't know exactly how I feel
about that exactly yeah I mean I yeah
it's an agreeable with you on that one I
just think it kind of makes you know my
family's kind of you know better but you
know just not to know the matter I think
a conversation
Sheldon appreciate the call thank you
appreciate it all right